the jurgen experience
especially in the field of alzheimer's
disease there was this huge revelation
recently that the past 16 years of
um alzheimer's research in many ways was
built on fraud
yeah i read that that was one of the
things that i wanted to talk to you
about because it's so crazy please tell
people about this because it's so insane
and it's so hard to believe that this
could happen in modern medicine and
especially with something that affects
so many people's alzheimer's but please
tell people about this study yeah so
basically
the prevailing
hypothesis as to what causes alzheimer's
disease over the past
century right has been what's called the
amyloid hypothesis so ever since alois
alzheimer discovered or named uh
alzheimer's disease in 1906
and looked into the brain of the cadaver
and saw these
um
plaques aggregating around neurons right
in the extracellular space around
neurons
the plaques have come to be
sort of the force the the focus of um
alzheimer's research really
and the idea was that these plaques were
the causative force in the in the
condition
um
much like the plaque on your teeth right
you see these plaques in the brain of an
of a person with alzheimer's disease
and so that's really been the target of
drug therapy and the idea was that until
we can find a drug that would reduce the
plaque burden reduce the plaque get rid
of the plaque in the brains of of a
senior person right somebody who's at
risk for developing alzheimer's disease
that it's a disease that you can't
prevent you can't there's nothing to do
to treat
but the problem was that they can never
actually tie the plaque
to
cognitive decline right like the
clinically meaningful symptom the
symptomology of alzheimer's disease that
it messes up your cognition that it
makes you you know that it makes you
forget your loved ones ultimately forget
who you are ultimately forgetting how to
eat right and that and
and nourish yourself
they could never tie those symptoms to
to the plaque right
until
a paper published in the journal nature
in 2006.
so what happened was this researcher
named sylvain lesni
at the university of minnesota
basically was looking into these the
brains of uh mice who are bred to
over express what's called
amyloid precursor protein which is the
precursor to amyloid beta
which is the protein that makes up sort
of the skeleton of these plaques that we
see aggregate right
so what he does what he did was he
isolated a subtype that he called a beta
star 56
and injected it into a
young and healthy mouse or rat mouse
and he saw the that mouse's cognition
rapidly declined so that was the missing
link right that he found a subtype of
this amyloid beta protein that serves as
the backbone of these plaques which
could never be pinned to the cognitive
decline itself right the memory loss
itself
but he claimed that he found it and when
injected into the
into the brain into the body of a
healthy mouse
he saw a rapid decline in terms of their
of their cognition right so that was the
missing link
and so at that point um
faith in the so-called amyloid
hypothesis was starting to wane
because they couldn't find effective
drugs
alzheimer's drug trials have a 99.6 fail
rate so
worse than for cancer or worse than for
any other any other disease state really
and um
and the drugs that are currently after
fda approved on the market they're
biochemical band-aids they're minimally
effective i mean they modulate various
neurotransmitters but
you know i've heard it described
like uh you know trying
expecting to remove amyloid from the
brain
uh of a person with alzheimer's disease
and to see their cognition come back is
sort of like thinking that if you remove
all the headstones from a grave you know
people will come back to life right like
there's widespread neuronal dysfunction
and death in the brain of somebody with
alzheimer's disease
and in tandem with that
uh scanning technology has allowed us to
look into the brains of healthy controls
and what we see is that there's amyloid
plaque in the brains of healthy controls
as well so there's no correlation
between amyloid burden in the brain and
one's cognitive abilities but
nonetheless when this paper came out in
2006
it renewed
fervor um
in terms of this hypothesis because he
found the subtype of amyloid that could
be injected into a young and healthy
mouse that would then impair seriously
impair their cognition right
and so
that that
renewed interest in this in this
hypothesis and it's what ultimately led
to the fact that
just a couple years ago two years ago um
there was a highly controversial drug
that was approved by the fda
called agicanamab or adjuhelm and this
is a drug
that
effectively reduced plaque burden in the
brain for the first time they found a
drug that could actually reduce
blackburn in the brain but it didn't
lead to any improvement in cognitive
symptoms nonetheless it was given the
green light against uh against
tons of opposition that the fda received
they put together a panel of 11 people
neuroscientists neurologists right eight
of them told the fda not to approve this
drug and what was the reason for that
the reason for that is that the drug
didn't didn't move the needle on any
clinically meaningful
uh symptom were there significant side
effects there were so 35 percent of the
people in the trial had significant
brain swelling and half of them had
uh bleeding associated with that brain
swelling because these are antibodies so
adjacent map is an antibody that
basically targets causes your own immune
system to target
the amyloid plaques right and so what
that's doing is causing an inflammatory
response in the brain right so 35 of the
patients in that in the in the phase 2
trials i believe
had horrible side effects and no
clinically meaningful uh effect on um on
their cognition but nonetheless because
it effectively did reduce the amyloid
black burden
there was this intense pressure right to
uh to get a greenlit because that's like
the amyloid hypothesis is right there
right uh-huh so
huge problem
one of the big uh
vocal sort of skeptics about this drug
adjecanimab is a guy a vanderbilt
researcher named matthew schrag
and so matthew tragg was like very vocal
vocally against the approval of this
drug which again doesn't do anything
right like
it's horrible risk of side effects no
clinically meaningful effect on on the
on the symptoms that we want to improve
right for a patient with alzheimer's
disease
and so he was vocally critical of that
and then he also was working on some
other some other drug
and he
uh so
what was revealed basically in the
science paper that came out was that
he was dabbling in a on a website called
pub peer which is
a site where you can go
it's known for post publication peer
review so before paper gets uh accepted
for publication it undergoes this peer
review process right and so
he found that there were a lot of sort
of red flags that were being brought up
on this message board essentially about
this nature paper this like seminal
nature paper that was published that
found to it was like the missing link
right between like the amyloid
hypothesis and like the clinically
meaningful meaningful um
symptoms meaning memory loss
and he did a bit of like image sleuthing
which is not generally part of the peer
review process right and he looked at
these um
the way data is illustrated in this in
this paper as it is in in research
generally it's called a western blot
which is like a visual representation of
of data the presence of proteins and so
forth and he found that they were all
for the most part fabricated in fact
this a beta star 56 wasn't found by any
other team hasn't been found by any
other team
it
it basically came to light that it was
essentially fake the whole thing was
faked what was the motivation for this
person to fake all this
because the thing i mean i think that we
we like to believe that science is this
good faith endeavor
towards human flourishing right
but in the industry of science
there are flawed humans just like there
are in every other industry right and
scientists in general i see this all the
time in nutrition online on social media
right social media is a great like
sort of
they say that sunlight is the best
disinfectant like social media is a
great way to kind of see
how this plays out right because
scientists are notoriously territorial
obstinate
they you know their their reputation
egotistical yeah their reputations are
everything right yeah
and um
i mean it's just like i see it i see it
every day it's humans yeah exactly yeah
so
yeah so there's bad apples right like i
think a lot of people in science
um like i'm i'm i live and breathe
nutrition i'm it's the thing that i'm
most passionate about like in life right
like fitness nutrition sleep disease
prevention my mom is what galvanized
that that passion for me right and what
my mom my mom went through and my desire
to prevent it from happening to others
that i care about and ultimately people
you know from all walks of life
but a lot you know a lot of people go
into science go into medicine because
it's just it's a career path right right
it's a career path for somebody wanting
validation it comes with prestige it
comes with money comes with all the
things that that like makes sense that a
person would want right but then ego
gets in the way and it and it becomes
really problematic i mean you see it in
nutrition all the time you see it
nutrition
like all the freaking time so this
person that fabricated the study and
fabricated all this data what
consequences are there for that person i
mean i think that the the department of
justice is is going to be looking into
it but
but um i'm gonna be looking into it i
mean this is if they're not already yeah
yeah if they're not already but i
personally so one of the worst things
about
this right
is it's not just like the lost time and
all the money that went to continue
looking down this sort of path of the
amyloid hypothesis right looking in the
wrong place really because amyloid is
there but it's sort of like what you see
in cholesterol in like atherosclerosis
right like cholesterol it's like
everybody like has pointed at
cholesterol as being the bad guy because
cholesterol is clearly there in
atherosclerotic plaques right but what's
causing it to be there that's the
question that these researchers should
have been asking all along and some have
right like there there have been other
like my mentor as i mentioned you know
at cornell who have been lucky to lucky
enough to work with over the years on
certain projects um you know knew that
that there was another way it's this
glucose hypometabolism right it's like
but there's no money in that there's no
money in saying like make keep yourself
as insulin sensitive as possible you
know reduce your exposure to
environmental pollutants don't hit your
head too hard you know all these
different modifiable risk factors it's
not as it's not it's not druggable the
way that this like amyloid beta
protein um is is druggable
and so i think the worst thing about it
is that
anybody who would advance an alternate
viewpoint over the past couple of
decades would be ridiculed and silenced
by the quote
amyloid mafia and i was the i this
happened to me
when i first started doing my
documentary
um
little empty boxes which when i first
started doing it uh it had a different
name i called it it was called breadhead
and i could talk about why i named that
but that was always a sort of a working
title
for the project but somebody at one of
these foundations right like
um
there's all these like big like
alzheimer's foundations
uh i'm lucky to be working on this
project with one who really believes in
me on the project the alzheimer's
foundation of america but there are
these other non-profits that really what
they are is just like a front for
you know perpetuating the status quo and
keeping the sort of the funding pipeline
open for drug discovery
and so when i first got started doing
working on this on my film i did a
kickstarter campaign for it
and
one of these non-pro quote unquote
non-profits right
deeply invested in the amyloid
hypothesis came out and wrote an uh an
op-ed in the wall street journal
disparaging me in my project and any
other alternate sort of viewpoint and
talking glowingly about that adjective
drug which at the time had yet to be
approved right
and it was so like painful to me at the
time because i was like working on this
project out of the love and passion that
i had for my mom and my desire to get
the science out to catalyze you know
interest in this science it takes 17
years on average for what's discovered
in science to be put into day-to-day
clinical practice so i was like that's
that's time we don't have to lose when
the brains of our loved ones are at
stake
and so
yeah i was like directly sort of in the
crosshairs at the time for this like
this amyloid mafia i was like directly
affected by it because this medication
is profitable yeah because the
medication is profitable and that the
whole avenue was thought to you know if
you could find a drug that would reduce
amyloid burn in the brain i mean that
makes that's going to make sure he's
really happy and this drug is it still
being prescribed yeah it's uh it's uh
it's approved it's approved and so
there's no real way of telling how many
people have died from this drug because
most of the people that are taking this
drug already experiencing this
neurodegenerative disease and you could
easily chalk it off to that being the
cause of death
yeah i mean i i can't speak to
like you know
people's experiences on it currently but
i do know that
um that the trials were you know i mean
if i had a loved one based on what i
know about this drug in those trials my
my loved one
currently would not be on that drug they
would be perhaps experimenting with uh
you know and this is a very difficult
sort of road to go down i guess it's
easier to say if i had dementia right
if i myself had dementia i would be
experimenting with a ketogenic diet on
myself and other ketogenic therapies
because ketogenic diets
what they do so as i mentioned in the
alzheimer's brain
the ability to generate energy
from glucose is reduced by about
forty five fifty percent its ability to
generate energy from ketone bodies is
unperturbed
so the idea is that a ketogenic diet can
essentially keep the lights on in the
alzheimer's brain it's not a cure
but um but there has been uh research
um on patients with alzheimer's disease
mild to moderate alzheimer's disease
that ketogenic ketogenic diet
intervention can actually improve
functional capacity in those patients
which is everything right
you